here in this video we are going to
discuss about the two famous meccas of
recent times
the jaegers of pacific rim and mecca
godzilla of the monsterverse we are
going to compare them
side by side as they are the most
effective kaiju killing weapons of man
that has ever been created in their own
respective universes of course
but what if robot godzilla happens to
enter the pacific rim world
and of course he will be the bad guy so
how would the jaegers fare against him
so we are going to go into detail about
the specs their powers
and abilities and also what will be the
outcome
of a one-on-one battle and how many
jaegers would it take to bring down
mecha g
so now let's get down with this sickness
so on one corner we have the jaegers
they are a special type of mobile weapon
system created by the united nations
under the flag of the jaeger program the
jaegers were the most effective
they were the first and the last line of
defense against the kaiju during the
kaiju war
as an alternative to nuclear weaponry
jagers were designed to generate as much
kinetic energy
as tactical ordnance they were built to
match the estimated scale of
kaiju and to minimize damage created by
conventional weaponry
they are as powerful as can be and are
piloted by two humans that share a
mental ling
through a technology called the drif in
order to be able to drive the massive
meccas
and on the other corner we have the most
powerful entree of the monsterverse
a machine that was designed to bring
down godzilla himself
and was designed to resemble the king of
the monsters maybe not
twin level but nonetheless similar in
appearance mechagodzilla was initially
completely under the control of ren
serizawa a human
who uses a neural interface controlling
mechagodzilla
like the extension of his own body
similar to the drift in the pacific rim
jaegers however once king kidora's
consciousness takes over
of the machine mechagodzilla becomes
incredibly violent and destructive
so first of all we are going to do a
quick size comparison of these two types
of mechas
or most specifically the many jaegers vs
mega godzilla
well the star of the first rim movie was
gypsy danger and she was 260 feet tall
whereas the others like striker eureka
and crimson
typhoon were around 250 feet tall while
the biggest were coyote tango
and cherno alpha at 30 feet taller
around 280 feet in height
uprisings jagers were also similar in
size between 250 and 280 feet
they were dwarfed in front of the mega
kaiju which was around 500 feet tall
now mechagodzilla on the other hand was
bigger than godzilla which was 400 feet
tall
it is estimated to be around 450 feet in
height
which would make it similar in size as
the mega gaidu
so mkg would tower over all the jaegers
then we come to the power systems the
jaegers were powered mostly by nuclear
reactors and as such could function for
a very long time
which makes their endurance only limited
by the pilots that drive the machines
mechagodzilla however was initially
powered in a similar manner but later on
the power core was replaced by a
synthetic recreation of the energy
source
that powered the hollow earth giving it
almost unlimited power
therefore making its endurance almost as
long as its lifespan of the mecca
and since it was taken over by the
consciousness of ghidorah
the lifespan would also be limitless so
there is no chance the jaegers
are living or outlasting mecca g in a
fight
exhaustion is not an option now we come
to the weapon systems let's start with
mechagodzilla
it has a wide array of weapons it can
use in a fight firstly there are the
stun missiles that are fired from its
shoulders with similar power as the
chess cannon of striker eureka
it has a very impressive melee combat
package with plasma power punches
grappling abilities a tail drill and
rockets that enhance its speed
and strike power its most powerful
weapon is the proton screen beam
that has the same power as the atomic
breath but most importantly
it has fast human-like reflexes which
makes it almost like a martial artist
which is seen as it was fighting close
quarters with the big g
the jaegers also have a wide array of
weapons such as
missiles swords and other plasma weapons
as well but
their most disadvantageous
characteristic is their relatively slow
reflexes
which would put them in a tight spot in
a battle against a fast enemy
anyway so in a one-on-one battle there
is absolutely no chance a single jaeger
can even stand a chance against a bigger
more durable and more agile mecha
godzilla which has
even more powerful weapons so what about
a group of jaegers then
fighting it like the way they for the
mega kaiju well
if you remember the battle was still in
the sight of the mega kaiju in the movie
and it was only because the mega kaiju
had another objective to complete
that allowed gypsy avenger to meteor
strike it from the air
killing it otherwise the creature would
have torn the remnants of the
destroyed jagers into bits so what about
a similar fight against mega godzilla
we can clearly say that the mecca was
more powerful than the mega guys who
given its
weapons and powers are at the least
equal in power
therefore since mecca has no other
objective than complete destruction
it's fair to say that it would be the
clear winner against a group of 5-6
jaegers as in the battle against the
mega kaiju
so the question is how many jaegers
would it take to defeat the mecca
10 20 or all of them combined
an army of jaegers would be the only way
the mecca could be taken down for the
count
and that is with a clear strategy of
avoiding the total annihilation when it
comes
to the mecca using the proton scream
against them
it would take the best of the jaegers
acting as distraction while battling
mechagodzilla
and a few of them using a suicide
nuclear attack on it
in order to secure a win in any way they
would have to suffer massive casualties
in order to win the battle
but that is up to you to decide in the
comments below
so do put in your thoughts and tell us
what you think and now we come to the
end of the video
do click that like button for support
and also remember to subscribe to be a
part of the minecube family
hit that bell button as well for regular
updates on monster videos
right here on this channel till the next
one take care fam